[拍手]
今から約2年前私はカナダのトロントに
住んでいました
現在と同じく
キャリアカウンセラーとして日々学生さん
や社会人の方に向けて
キャリア設計のサポートを行っていました
そんなある日1人の学生さんから
泣きながら電話がかかってきました
それは
ずっと憧れていた航空会社がコロナの影響
によって採用を中止してしまったという
ことでした
彼女は小学校5年生の時からそこの会社で
知恵になることを目指していてそのために
たくさん努力もされてきました
そんな彼女の幼い頃からの夢が
突然
閉ざされてしまった瞬間でした
そんな時
皆さんがどうされますか
逆境に立たされるとまではいかなくても
きっと環境の変化に戸惑った経験というの
は
皆さんあるのではないでしょうか
皆さんにとって一番身近な環境の変化意図
しない環境の変化っていうのは何で言うと
学生生活そのものなんじゃないかなと思い
ますで今回は
多分私よりも人生経験がありそうな方も
いらっしゃると思うんですがあのその方々
の中でも
きっとこのコロナっていう環境は思っても
見なかった変化が起きているんじゃないか
なと思います
でそんな
理想と現実このギャップの中で
立ち止まってしまうこともたくさんあると
思うんですがそんな
逆境だったりとか
意図しない環境の変化にの中でも
立ち止まらずに進み続けられる人というの
と
困って
立ち止まってしまう人っていうのがいます
その差は一体何でしょうか
それは
現在地を
テントしてみるか
線としてみるか
現在地をテントしてみる例えば
就職活動をテントしてみるとその就職活動
の結果一つで
自分の気持ちが大きく左右されてしまい
ます
その一つの結果だったりとか一つの環境の
変化にいちいちご
感情を左右されないためにはちょっとした
考え方の工夫が必要です
今回は
株式会社私という1つの考え方を
使って
逆境に倒れない
強い軸の作り方とあと未来への線のつなぎ
方というのをお話しさせていただければと
思います
まず
株式会社私っていうのはこれ勝手に私が
命名したんですけれども
自分自身を会社として考えるというような
考え方になります
で
自分自身を会社として考えるのでできれば
いい会社にしたいですよね
皆さんが思ういい会社っていうのはどんな
んでしょうか
私が思ういい会社っていうのは
関わる人みんなが幸せで
社会に貢献していて
安定している
すなわちみんなにとっていいことをし
ながら
持続的な活動をしている会社なんじゃない
かなと思います
で
みんなにとっていいことっていうのは
とっても大切なんですがでも株式会社私で
は
自分にとっての幸せっていうことも追求し
てもらいたいです
例えばですけど
自分にとって
幸せっていうのをこう見ずに過ごして
しまうとどれだけ社会に対していいことを
していても
例えばどれだけ人に喜んでもらったとして
も
自作した活動っていうのはなかなか難しい
んですよね
ボロボロになって進めなくなってしまって
は
意味がないのでやはり
自分の幸せっていうことも大切にして
いただきたいなと思います
によって持続的な活動をしていく中で
やはり
軸になるものが必要なんですが
それが
ミッションビジョンバリューです
でミッションビジョンバリューは
自分のこれから何をしていくのかっていう
ような方向性だったりとかどうしていくの
か何でやるのかっていうことを決める時期
になります
そして
株式会社私のもう一つのものっていうと
一人株主総会で
一人株主総会ってなんじゃそりゃやって
感じだと思うんですけれども
自分の向かっている方向が正しいかって
いうのをもう一人の自分の心の中にもう
一人株主の自分っていうものを作って
第三者自分の中でなんですけど
第三者目線から
自分の向かっている方向が正しいかどう
かっていうのを判断してもらうような
会議になります
まずでは1つ目のミッションビジョン
バリューについてなんですけれども
皆さん
ミッションビジョンバリューって聞いた
ことはある方ちょっと手を上げていただい
てもいいですか
ありがとうございますじゃあ
次に
自分自身のミッションビジョンバリュー
もうどれが一つでもいいので
考えたことあるよっていう方いらっしゃい
ますか
あいらっしゃいますねあなんかちょっと
嬉しいですありがとうございますで
ミッションビジョンバリューっていうのは
あの
会社によってちょっとそれぞれ捉え方だっ
たりとか考え方っていうのが
少しずつ異なるんですが今回は私がこれが
一番
考えやすいんじゃないかなっていうあの
方法をお伝えしたいと思います
で
ミッション
ビジョンバリューそれぞれの意味なんです
が
ミッションは
氏名
存在に
使命とか存在意義とか急に言われても
そんなあの大きなこと考えたことないって
思うかもしれないんですがやっぱり
皆さんの人との関わりの中で生活をして
いくと思うので
自分の役割があった方が心が安定するん
ですよね
で
ミッションっていうのはこの
皆さんと関わっているこの社会の中で
自分がどういうことで貢献していったら
自分自身が幸せかっていうことを
考えていただきたいんですけれどもこれは
普遍的なものなので一度考えていただい
たらこれをずっと継続して
持ち続けるというような
自分の中の
使命志になります
しいきなりミッションを持とうと言われて
も
きっとそんなの考えたことなければ
なかなか思いつかないししっくりする言葉
っていうのが
降りてこないと思うんですよねなので最初
しっくりくる言葉が見つからない間はもう
どんどんどんどん
ブラッシュアップしていって
変えていってくださいでそのうちあもう
これが自分のミッションだっていうものが
見つかるのでそうなったらそれを自分の
ミッションとして普遍的なものとして
てくださいはい
次にビジョンなんですが
ビジョンは実現したい未来
理想の姿ですねこれは中長期的なゴールな
んですがこの
子が上でこの志を果たすためにはどういう
ゴール設定が必要かということを考えて
いきます
で最後にバリューなんですがバリューって
いう言葉自体は
価値なんですがこの自分自身が提供できる
価値それが転じて
定期的に見直していく行動指針に
例えば
自分自身が今現在提供できる価値っていう
と何だろうなあの
人前で人を
持ち上げることができるとかあとは計画的
に行動ができるとかそんな感じで人とまあ
約束できるような自分の価値ですね私は
こういうことができますそしてこういう
ことをやっていくことによって最終的に
ビジョンが達成することができるんです」
っていうものですねでこれを
簡単に捉えるためには登山として考えると
わかりやすいかなと思うんですけれども
登山で考えると
ミッションは
山に
屋内に登ることですよね
でビジョンで言うと
どこの山を登っていくのかバリューで言う
と
矢野に登るためにどんなことに気をつけ
ないといけないのかということになります
これをさらに踏み込んで
登山家さんが
ミッションビジョンバリューを考えたとし
たらっていうことを私の中に勝手に考えて
みたんですけれども
ミッションまず使命ですねでこれは一見
無言に見えることに挑戦しこれすいません
字間違えてるんですが人々に勇気を与える
これ結構大きなミッションですよねでその
次が
ビジョンで1年後に
単独で富士山に登場するあともう一つが
山頂で最高のコーヒーを飲んで
幸せだと叫ぶでなんでこれ2つやっている
かというとやっぱりビジョンて
明確で自分の中でしっかり頭にイメージ
できるもんの方が
ゴールに達成しやすいんですねなので
わかりやすい1年後に
単独で富士山に登場するっていうのと
さらにそこに登場した時の自分の姿ですね
その両方をイメージしてもらうためにこの
2つの基準を設定し
ましたそして最後バリュー
計画的に行動する
危険回避のため既にプランBを考える
情報収集を
怠らないこのようなことがバリューとして
挙げられるかなと思います
でですね
例えばこの
ミッションを持ってビジョン達成のために
努力をしていたとしても
例えばその前に
怪我をしてしまっただったりとかもう
そもそも富士山口ちゃダメよもう噴火する
らしいよってなったりするともうほぼ持っ
てたビジョンって使えなくなってしまい
ましたね
でそんな時でもこのミッション一見無謀に
見えることに挑戦し人々に勇気を与えると
いうものがあればこのビジョンだけじゃ
なくてもいいんですよ別に他の方法もある
わけですよねそこでこのミッションを持っ
た状態でビジョンを変えてまた新たに前に
進み続けるということができますこれが
逆境でも強くなるっていうような
軸になります
で次に一人株主総会についてなんです
けれども一人株主総会の説明をする前に
まず
株式会社の仕組みについて簡単にご説明を
させていただきます
株式会社の仕組み
多分
経営学部の先生たちもいるのでそんな人々
の中でこう話すのはちょっと恥ずかしいん
ですが
株式会社の仕組みっていうのは
株式っていう証明書ですねと
彼に
資金を提供してもらってその
資金を元手に経営を行っていくっていうの
が株式会社ですでその資金提供をした人の
ことを株主って言うんですけれどもその
株主は
会社が利益を上げると
配当を受け取れるんですねでそして
会社の経営について
形の思想会に質問したりとか
意見を出すことが
これが株式会社っていうものの仕組みに
なっています
でこの仕組みを使って考えるのが一人株の
思想会なんですけれども
自分の中に2人の自分を作っていきます
まず
社長も自分っていうのは今こうやって人の
前に立っていたりとか今後自分がどういう
ことを進んでいってやっていきたいのかと
いうことを
意思決定していく
表側の自分になりますで表側の自分って
いうのはもちろんそのいろんなところで話
をしたいとか
自分のやりたいように意思決定をしていく
んですけれどもその代わり
自分の中の株主に
説明責任があります
で株主の自分というのは内側の自分で
質問や意見を出す自分になります
例えば何か新しいことを始めるだったりと
か何か状況が変わるとなった時に
本当にそれがベストな方法なのかとかあと
は
実際それをやっていて本当にあなたは幸せ
なのですかとかそんな風に
自分の中にこう質問をどんどんしてくれる
のが
株主の自分になります
で
新たな決断をする時や状況が変わる時って
いうのは人に株主総会を行ってほしいん
ですね
思ってその一人株主総会では
自分の
ミッションビジョンバリューに
沿った行動ができているかそれに沿った
未来に意思選択ができているかっていう
ところをしっかりと
自分の中の株主に発表していくっていう
ような
流れになります
やはり
自分の
決めたことでまたつもりでも
自分が納得してないとたとえ人に話すじゃ
なくて自分の中の株主に話すっていうこと
ですら
詰まってしまうことっていっぱいあるん
ですよね
状況が変わった時とかあとはそれこそその
逆境に立たされた時とか
流されないといけないとかその
自分が思い描いてた道と全然違うところに
行ってしまうっていう時って
もう身を任せた方が楽なのかなって思う
こともたくさんあると思うんですがその別
に
長いに自分のミッションバリューに
ちょっと一見沿ってないからちょっと
頑張ってそれを半分買っていかないといけ
ないっていうわけでは決してなくて
自分の今
持っているミッションビジョンバリューと
違うように見えても最終的にここに
たどり着くんだということを
自分の中で自分の株主に
説明することさえできれば
わざわざ
アランナミに立ち向かっていく必要はあり
ませんただしどれだけ一生懸命考えたとし
ても
全然自分の中で納得するような
答えが出てこないとかどう
頑張ったってミッションビジョンに
バリューで
合わないんだとなってしまった場合は
きっと高校を変えたりとかするのが
自分にとっていいんじゃないかっていう
判断基準にもなります
そうやって
自分との中で一つ一つ意思決定の
プロセスを踏んでいくことによって
自分の道は自分で選んでいるんだ自分の道
は自分が納得して進んでいるんだという
強い意志になりますそうやって自分との
信頼関係を積み重ねていくことによって
新たな道がどんどん開けることになります
そして
先ほどお伝えしたようにこの
第三者自分の中の財産者ですね
株主っていう人がいるおかげで
自分主観の自分社長の自分がもう
逆境に立たされて真っ暗な状態になって
しまったとしても
違う方向から見てくれる株主の自分がいれ
ばまた
新しい方向だったりとか
新しい道が見えてくることに
なってこの株式会社私っていう
新しいそのミッションビジョンバリューっ
ていうのの考えるジップとさらに一人株主
総会っていう
自分が向かっている方向が正しいのかこの
2つも方法を使って
自分が楽しく過ごしていけるような
道を探し続けていってほしいなと思います
最後に私自身のミッションビジョン
バリューの
ミッションだけお伝えしたいと思います
私のミッションは
一人一人が個性を生かしてそれぞれが
自分
オリジナルの幸せを見つけることができる
社会を実現する
今日ってお話を聞いてくださった皆さんが
このお話を通して
少しでも自分らしく
楽しい人生を歩んでいけることを
心から願っています
ご清聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]